the jurgen experience
undisputed the undisputed champ ladies
and gentlemen it feels amazing god how
good does that feel for you oh
top of the world liberating after all
that [ __ ] you had to take from people
for so long how many months was it
13 months before i could get back in
there teen months of people talking [ __ ]
yeah it's a long time it's a long time
like but how sweet must it have been
when they raise your hand and you got
the w and
still
it was kind of a mind [ __ ] a little bit
because
it was a split decision which i was like
wait i i mean like going back now i can
see why people were saying that but in
my head i thought i had that thing
locked up easy dead to rights and uh i
was really confident going into the uh
scorecards and then when that happened i
was like you got to be kidding me
they're really trying to take this away
from me after 13 months i worked this
hard
but um you got it yeah that was a weird
split decision i mean it was a very good
fight but you definitely won the fight i
watched it again today actually i
haven't i've watched it one time with
people normally after the fight within i
usually watch it that night and i
usually watch it a couple of times and i
analyze it and i break it down take
notes wins losses because that's how you
grow but for this one
i just wanted to break and just get away
from the sport a little bit and it's
kind of decompressed because like i said
man 13 months is a long time to just
have people just chirping at you and you
can't physically do anything because
you're healing so um i was just really
happy that i got it done but now i need
to go back and start to get back on that
horse a little bit to get ready for the
next one yeah go back and watch it
you're gonna appreciate it it's it's a
great fight it's a very good fight
but you're just different you're so much
different than the first fight which
made you know for someone who's had neck
injuries myself
i was wanting to ask you like how bad
was your neck [ __ ] up before the first
fight yeah so going into the fight it
was [ __ ] up so just to give a kind of
a storyline
college wrestling freshman year me and
this guy talking [ __ ] to each other we
call each other out he's up a weight
class for me but he last year he
wrestled the same weight class as me
i'm very competitive that kid was
competitive we're both from new york so
we go after he slams me spikes me on my
head his name is dave
uh
spiked me on my head i had stingers so
anytime i would turn my head i would
find like a radiant pain from like the
crown of my head all the way down to
like
somewhere around that c
c disc like right around that area and
then each year it got progressively
worse like that got better but each year
after that wrestling pulling on the head
we do hand fighting drills where we put
our hands behind our back and you got to
keep your head up in a wrestling
position and someone your partner is
just pulling on your neck and ganking
and yanking it so that didn't help
jiu-jitsu didn't help all these other
things so over the years it got
progressively worse i have mris
dating back from
i think 2014 when when i had my ufc
debut and every time was about my neck
almost every single fight i had an mri
about my neck because i kept thinking
okay this is the time i might have to
get a fix this is the time and we were
able to just let it heal
do pt and then before the first yawn
fight when he pulled out i was
contemplating on pulling out because my
neck had a really bad flare-up and i
thought i wasn't gonna make it to the
fight
and um thankfully he pulled out
gave me some time to do some pt at the
ufc pi that helped out a ton all
everyone over there and then i got a
shot but the funny part about the shot
the cortisone shot they put it in the
wrong spot but he's the doctor said oh
you but you'll still
get the effects he put it like a a disc
level too high wow so c67 was mine he
put it in the c5 c6 he said i'm like
well it's not the end of the world but i
did feel some relief but then i go
through training i'm rolling with this
guy at 10th planet
and i'm in vegas and um it's a guy i've
never trained with before jumps on my
neck and a guillotine cranks my neck on
a flow roll to warm up it's the very
second flow roll
right before the fight again i think
about three weeks before the fight and i
as soon as he did that and the role was
done
i i go to him i was like
i know the rest of this week is shot and
i'm probably gonna be out um for a
couple of days because it is and that's
exactly what happened and then we had
the fight whatever
after the knee
i started having some atrophy because
now they're rushing me to get because i
i texted dana when i was when you stay
after the knee tell everybody when you
got
illegally yeah from the first fight um
in march march 6 2021 that night went to
the hospital and uh i texted dana white
and i told him like i want i want to
have
the rematch and
get this done and settle the right way
like as soon as we can kind of thing
they were offered me to fight like i
think like two months what was it march
april may i was like dude if i was
suspended if that was a legal shot i
would have been suspended there's no way
i can fight in may like if it was a
legal fight ending sequence i would not
even be clear to to compete did you get
concussed from that 100
so
my analysts out there my doctors that
know what a concussion is they know all
the symptoms they know what a concussion
is i threw up later that night they
thought i was drinking i was like i
didn't drink my friends were there
and we they came to see me so they all
spent a ton of money come out buying uh
tickets um for the fight for the flight
and
some of them even gathered at the house
that couldn't pay for the tickets to get
out so
i had about 30 something people at the
house
and here i come back from the hospital
and i still don't remember much of the
night i had to get like people to kind
of help me recall what actually happened
and when we're at the house
i kind of want to just go to bed but
then at the same time i felt bad because
everyone spent so much money to come see
me you know these are friends from
college from high school middle school
so at that point i'm kind of like well i
can't just
be mopey and you know i have these guys
trying to get lift me up hey guy you you
made it here one of the hardest things
to do is to get to the top to even earn
a title shot everything you had to do
just to get the title shot
um you finally got it it's not the way
you want to win but you get an
opportunity to do it again you know i
had to keep it in perspective and they
helped me do that and they just they
wanted me to have a toast so i had a
toast with the with the with my
with my friends and family and people
took that and i never posted anything
but people took that because my friends
were posting stuff because they were
excited i mean i can understand why me
i'm not very excited as an athlete you
know you know no one wants to win like
that so it's not a very exciting moment
but i did understand this that this was
special to have people that cared about
you
and have been following my career for so
long to come out
and want to hang out so for that moment
for me it was just really
cool just to to take that moment in with
them like hey man like after this i got
to kind of get back to work and uh we
had a toast i said a couple words we'll
do it again blah blah blah and you know
they said to the champion whatever there
was videos out then it looked like i was
faking i'm like guys i didn't know
there's a protocol
how you're supposed to react after being
illegally need to in the head from a
shot you don't even see right while
you're exhausted in a high stakes fight
i didn't know there was a certain way
you're supposed to act i'm like was i
supposed to pretend like i was being
like macho like i'm just trying to
gather myself but after that knee
i tried to get back into the gym like a
week later i started to hit the bag to
try to see if i can make may happen but
i told my manager that's probably not
going to be a go they asked for june
that would have been the brandon moreno
fight i think they had that rematch and
that would have been cool but i couldn't
do push-ups i hit the bag i was getting
radiating pain down my arm and uh i
couldn't do pull-ups push-ups
um bag work all that stuff so this disc
that you had was it bulging at this
point or had it deteriorated to the
point where it's bone on bone like where
were you at so
that's a good question i never really
asked it's just i'm having i was having
pressing from i guess herniation is when
it's like spilling out yeah so it was
that's what it is yes herniating yeah so
i guess that would be the proper term so
it was spilling out into the spinal
column and pushing on the nerve and they
said if it doesn't unblock within two to
four weeks
that muscle could just end up just being
like i could just lose muscle and that
would just be the that's boss ruden have
you ever seen boss rooten's arm his arm
i haven't seen it but i've heard about
it it's crazy he has one arm he calls
baby arm because it's like it's so
atrophied it's like he has nothing there
his other arm's jacked and he's got his
right arm he goes i can't even hold a
gallon of milk out it's crazy yeah and
people don't understand how big of like
how severe of a thing that really is in
years and years and years for him and it
still hasn't grown back exactly so that
could have been me
yeah try to be tough and say you know
i'm just gonna go fight and um
they looked at it again and surgery was
the option i was so afraid to do the
surgery though because
i just wasn't sure how that was gonna
so let's explain the surgery you have uh
an artificial disc this replacement yeah
yeah and weidman had the same thing
right so he did like a
discectomy he never had an artificial
disc no he does yeah but the first one
he did was a discectomy i think where
they just clean it out yeah and then i
guess that didn't do too well and then
they went in and actually took it out
and replace it so we're like blood
brothers so when he
so when he had his uh disc you at least
had a friend that it was a training
partner you knew well and you got a
chance to ask him what the recovery was
like and how is he doing is he is he
good to go with that now or is he having
issues well he fought after i mean he
fought you right you ride a hall i mean
obviously well that was that was a crazy
yeah
but he's trained after that um
i think he actually fought even
other fights after that as well
if i'm not mistaken i think he had a
couple of fights i think he had a couple
but he said doesn't bother him same
thing with me you could barely even see
my scar
and so your neck feels just like a
normal neck now it's weird so i i hit
the doctor up um dr robert walker's
watkins jr he's the man super cool super
accessible and um
really like checks up on his patients
which which not a lot of people do that
and
thank god he was the guy who did handle
the procedure because i think he did a
phenomenal job from what i know and um
just being very hands-on with me walking
me through the process when i'm asking
him about my recovery from a
neurological standpoint when i'm trying
to get back into training and i'm like
not feeling the muscle endurance
and i still feel like i'm slowing down
and uh
he did a good job walking me through
everything just saying like hey man it
just kind of just takes time to stay
with the stuff and the protocol as long
as you're not having any pain kind of
thing so when you're saying muscle
endurance like like your neck was
fatiguing is that what you're saying
just about everything everything like a
lot quicker like like physically i
looked good
but like internally like all the the
neurological things like the wiring it's
like since they severed the nerves i
guess it just took a while for your
nerves well i mean i would imagine like
when you cut the neck that's there's
probably nerve endings in there they
don't cut your nerves well i know i
think the nerves move out of the way or
something like that they push them out
of the way yeah but when they do cut in
like something happens there
mechanically where you have to
like get everything back to working the
way that was before do you have an image
of what it looks like now like an mri or
an x-ray or something like that where we
could see the fake disc that always
freaks me out um i might have something
on my ig
eddie bravo's got one of those uh in his
lower back he's got a fake one i know a
lot of guys that have them now you know
it's one of the things that you know we
were talking about people that have uh
issues over time and get surgeries over
time from jiu-jitsu like everybody has
something eventually but
a lot of guys are getting disc
replacements yeah i i do have a picture
posted i mean it might take me a while
to find it because i don't have one on
instagram yeah
you'll find it but um
yeah man it was just a crazy process
like just to get back and
after the knee
then i did the surgery and i was afraid
to do it because i just wasn't sure what
i was gonna look like because i there
was only like three people who have done
it allen joe band he was very great with
me as well oh allen did yeah and i think
we had we actually had the same doctor
and um i asked him about it and we got
to talk and that was cool that he got to
express everything and kind of
similar feelings for the two of us so
that was amazing to talk to him talk to
wyman i talked to wyman's doctor but i
almost felt like he the guy didn't
really you know i'm not trying to offend
anybody but it just felt like he did
doesn't didn't really
no i don't say care but it didn't seem
like he was really
it was i feel like i was just another
number to him kind of thing that happens
with a lot yeah so i just i think that's
the most pc way to put it bummer yeah
when doctors start thinking people are
just like numbers like this is my neck
we're talking about no i'm like and i'm
not just a regular i mean i am a regular
guy but not just a i don't do a regular
job [ __ ] regular guys you're the [ __ ]
bantamweight champion in the world
and your job is crazy as [ __ ] oh there
it is wow wow
so that's
articulating disc
so that disc uh allows your neck to move
as freely as if you had the regular disc
tissue in there yeah and you don't do
you feel anything in there so that's
what i was oh yeah that's what i was i
was gonna say so i hit the doctor up um
dr watkins and i go
is it weird does that feel like
sometimes i need to oil my neck like a
like a car
because it feels like the joint it gets
like dry because i can hear it go
sometimes not all the time um
got my shake shack is that right after
you had it done yeah wow got shake shack
out there i needed that go back to the
other picture jamie shake shack needs to
step their [ __ ] up though man they do
yeah what's the matter like just a
service sometimes is yeah it's like
but they'd make a damn good milkshake so
i'm okay with it that is wild looking at
that neck thing
you